as you can already see crime in america
is on the rise and americans are getting
worried we have brand new
poll numbers from fox news 70 of people
feel there is more
crime in the country now compared to
2020 with 54
saying crime has gone up in their own
local area
it's getting so bad even some liberals
are concerned that maybe they shouldn't
have been so quick
to defund the police joining me now the
great dan van gina host of the dan
bungino show streaming
weekdays on fox nation 12 to 3 o'clock
dan i got to be honest with you um yes
it is
true that they wanted to defund the
police they have defunded the police
but crime was already going up in these
liberal cities
before that when they defunded the
police it only exasperated the problem
right
yeah well i think the big question here
you're not wrong
certain crimes were going up shootings
and homicides were going up
but once we had we saw lockdowns what
happened after the lockdowns is you saw
you saw street robberies and other
things go down because
there was nobody on the street which
makes the increase in shooting and
homicides
even more unbelievable when you think
about it right but the real question
here is
why why why why what's behind this
why do liberals live in an alternate
reality it's a serious question
i know liberal oh my gosh why you always
yelling out of stand all the time
because you live in a planet no one else
lives on i mean you live on a planet
where taking money away from the police
firing police officers attacking police
officers and making them the object of
your scorn
somehow leads to better public safety i
just want you to know
no same person lives in that world but
you do
and the question lawrence is why why do
they believe that and the answer
is our media our media has polluted
the american media space for way too
long they told people police are
randomly hunting down black men
and assassinating them midday for doing
nothing wrong
and then people liberals who sucked it
up believed it and said well
police are public enemy number one we
damn well better get
rid of them and what happened now people
are dying then i want you to listen to
this site from
carmen best she was the former uh police
chief back
in uh seattle take a look into this
i would read stories about you know the
peaceful protest i go well
part of it was peaceful but i was
standing like 20 feet away from a hail
of rocks
you know and i was looking right at them
come hell down
like feet from me i was behind a
telephone pole but you know
once we know we're going to be getting
rocks and bottles don't ask
i have a responsibility as a chief to
make sure people have protective gear we
can't just leave them out there with the
soft hat and you know rocks are being
thrown
dan this is what you were talking about
when it concerns the media
and the question that i have is carmen
bess is an advocate for reforms in
police departments
she worked with the community she really
wanted to help bring people together
and even someone like her was lambasted
they
they essentially cut her salary until
she resigned
yeah that's why she's the former police
chief she told the truth
you know lawrence there's a reason i
opened up with the media obviously you
know i i kind of know what stories we're
going to talk about tonight
and there's a common thread with all of
them again it's the media
how is it that seattle had an
insurrection in the middle
literal insurrection people said no this
is our territory
gave the double barrel middle finger to
the city of seattle said
we're just going to take this over
people were throwing rocks
people were being assaulted crimes were
happening in this independent
insurrection area
they just randomly declared and no one
in america really thought it was a big
deal
why because the media told you it wasn't
a big deal because it's a liberal city
lawrence i assure you if that was the
middle of
stuart florida where i live which is a
relatively conservative area and it was
a bunch of mega sign wearing people
who took over a portion of stewart it
would have been on the front page of the
new york times
but the media is destroying the country
and they're doing it deliberately
then i need you to level with me because
i met you when i was a young libertarian
back at freedomworks you know you've
always been supportive of me we've had
passionate conversations about the state
of this thanks brother i appreciate it
what do you think it's gonna take you've
been a cop you have respect from people
in the community
hell i thought you was a brother when i
first met you so
how do how do we bring the folks
together
yeah well listen we did it i mean i mean
i lived through it with the broken
windows policing era
with rudy giuliani in new york city you
know we established they had a civilian
complaint review board so you know you
listen
police need oversight like everyone else
no good cop is going to say otherwise
but also you have to enforce the law
lawrence i worked in the 7-5
precinct in eastern new york broken it
was the most dangerous precinct in the
city
it was a largely minority precinct
overwhelmingly minority
people used to come out to me all the
time and say hey
this guy in the corner he's slinging
dope or whatever
please don't tell him i said anything i
please please i need you to do so he
would beg and i'd feel so
bad because i would say to myself you
know this place is ravaged with crime
and 90 of this precinct is full of good
people
having their lives torn apart by animals
in the middle of the street
and they want this cleaned up so how do
you do it you have to have good police
oversight obviously again no good cop
will tell you otherwise
but you have to have effective policing
where they enforce the law if you don't
have that you have chaos
civilization thin crust on a volcano
ellis said it a long time ago
you know what that thing crust is made
of police officers in our military
they're the ones out there enforcing the
law an international order that's
it what do you what i mean what do you
want lord of the flies
you want piggy with the you know get
thrown up with the little pig on the
stick that's what you'll have
that's what you'll have if you keep
attacking the police and that's
exactly what liberals and their media
allies wanted
and that's exactly what they're getting
right now with a what 800 percent
increase in crime in homicides in
portland 144
increase in la lawrence these are real
people dying this isn't a joke it's not
a talking point it's not a fox news
chiron talking point these are real body
bags
in the real world because really stupid
people
are making really dumb decisions and one
more thing minneapolis
after the george floyd incident 19
children since then
children shot kids kids because the cops
are being attacked over there instead of
handling the real problem
that incident of police misconduct the
great dan bongino folks
thank you brother i'll be watching your
new show hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else